ich bin schon sehr sehr lange auf dieser
plattform ion verweht hatte schon einige
kanäle am start und wollte jetzt einfach
mal rausfinden
ich kann das mit zu epischen sachen
nicht machen
hallo mein name ist luca blablabla ich
würde meine wasserflasche ich will heute
herausfinden was meinen frühesten
youtube-video mit mir ist ob was noch
existiert wir fangen an
wir befinden uns hier auf youtube
klicken oben einfach aussuchen geben mal
einfach erst mal konkreter rein wenn ich
konkret eingehen
natürlich hat er für einen kanal dann
hier meine neuesten videos dann
irgendwas anderes hier was auch von mir
oder von anderen youtube hochgeladen
wurde aber wir gehen jetzt einfach mal
nach ganz oben und klicken hier auf
filter und wenn dann schon okay erhoben
lade datum wird hier nach ablaufdatum
[Applaus]
jetzt ist das neueste ganz oben aber das
hier auch interessant wie die häufig
etwas hochgeladen wir konkreter
getroffenen disco botter fock
[Musik]
was wenn du ich wusste dass wir im
urlaub ein paar stalker hatten aber dass
mich jemand im club gefilmt hat das habe
ich jetzt nicht mitbekommen aber da
haben soll es heute gar nicht gehen
freunde sieht nur darum kräfte luca
lächerliche samels mega des anlage in
lübeck
das gucken
lechleiter immer den mund
[Musik]
damit wären besser geplant und immer den
gesetze auf jeden fall an der haustür
ein
als klassiker
aber wie bereits mehrmals gesagt haben
uns heute nicht versammelt um
irgendwelche neuen videos oder reaction
hier irgendwie zu machen oder irgendwie
sondern wir versuchen mein erstes
youtube-video zu finden in dem ich dabei
war oder was ich selber hochladen habe
wenn man auf meinem kanal von einfach
mal auf video draufklicken dann hier
rechts einfach mal hinzugefügt alt nach
neu ein gibt ein kombi nervig video auf
hoeneß jahren hey leute in diesem video
zeigt euch einfach mal hier in einer
zusätzlichen welt in minecraft ersten
jahr innerhalb von fünf minuten findet
dafür stelle ich mir eine neue welt die
ihr gesehen habt habe ich keinen spaß
so was früher hochladen als auf jeden
fall ist dieses video halt dem video was
man irgendwie auf meinen kanal findet
und wenn man da einmal nachschaut
liebmann hochgeladen am 12 08 2011 das
heute ein video finden war vor dem 12 08
2011 veröffentlicht wurde auf der
plattform von der stelle muss ich
wirklich mal ganz kurz sagen kraft da
war nicht mein erster youtube kanal also
mein erster youtube kanal war komplett
olg als noch einige von euch daran
erinnern sollten ich habe mir früher den
kanal konkrete erstellt um dort einfach
alleine so ein paar gaming videos
hochgeladen und das ist mir relativ früh
aufgefallen
irgendwie hatte ich noch mal klappt hoch
v just minecraft und deswegen habe ich
mir halt hier den kanal kong crafter
kreiert und aber etwas wie das konkret
über genommen crafter wegen minecraft
das heißt wir gehen hier oben endlich
konkrete einmal von quero lp und schau
mal ob wir da noch
[Musik]
einerseits ein let's play damals was ich
mit 3play gemacht habe und noch nicht
interview
das ist ja nicht wahr und hier kommt
einfach vom ballkleid der freestyle
wollt ihr eigentlich das jetzt noch mal
machen
also dass man like a und b ich höre euch
nein da muss ich höre ich will das nicht
machen ich schwöre euch wenn dieses
video hier auch keine ahnung wie viele
schaffen
1000 schon wert der gesellschaft gelegt
dann lade ich ein neues game video immer
wenn ich heute in folge haben die videos
gegen siebenstellige aufruf aber ich
muss halt einfach nicht weil mir die
angst davor
back to topic harry eingepackt man ja
noch ein paar schallplatten videos
andere kanäle wieder irgendwas was da
gespielt habe und so aber wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal wieder hoch zu dem
video und schauen uns mal die beiden
sachen ja an das eine video hier ist ein
letzte was 3play hochgeladen hat am 26
06 2011 das ist auf jeden fall in diesem
moment das frühe erste video was ist von
mir auf der plattform youtube gibt 26 6
2011 bei dem video bei dem anderen
wieder mit 20 6 2011 freunde
das interview ist das früheste video von
mir auf youtube das heißt letztlich lief
ich jetzt mal einfach und wir klicken
einfach mal in das interview
reinigungsunternehmen draußen vor den
bildschirmen heute war eine neue folge
von fischen vorgänger weiß hardy es mit
dabei ich war ja und unser gast ist aber
nicht ausgeschlossen
ja ich bin der lokale
doch ich muss mal ganz schluss aber
zurückgeben hat es das noch mal an
ja ich bin der luca ist auf youtube.com
p macht letztlich tutorial und alles
drumherum
tutorials
ich will noch die schweiz gekommen alles
liebe mannschaft gut sein
also ich mein ich sag dann noch mal am
ende und ich liebe mein kraft und ihrer
interviewpartner sagt einfach nur gut
habe ich auf jeden fall direkt
verschiffen zu beginnen die channel hat
derzeit 199 abonnenten ich glaube ich
hatte zu dem zeitpunkt irgendwie war
weiß ich nicht genau 1000 abonnenten
oder irgendwie so das war früher
wirklich ich will mir jetzt gar nicht
mehr das ganze interview anschauen weil
ich das logo
ja
das war mein logo aber wie immer wieder
zurück hier auf die suchseite dass sich
der kanal also ich habe niemals
beschreibung von wegen junge leute ich
hoffe der kanal wieder spaß machen wie
soll ein kanal einem spaß machen wir
schauen noch ganz immer noch mal so ein
bisschen durch und gucken mal ob hier
vielleicht noch mal von früher irgendwie
ein video ist minecraft anfang
von dem kanal konkreter lp das hat den
namen geklaut auf seite 2 befinden sich
jetzt auch keine krassen videos
irgendwie von mir aber ich würd sagen
wir wir klicken einfach mal auf das
display hier draufhalten let's play mit
3play gemacht das war früher irgendwie
so ein internet freund von mir und
irgendwie hatten wir nicht mehr zu tun
ich weiß nicht mehr wollen das lag ich
glaube das macht doch keine videos mehr
seit ein paar jährchen aber ihr seht
meine view auf jeden fall auf der
rechten seite und auf der linken seite
also ich würd mal auf ok drückt auf
pause das war die zeit wo ich noch kein
mikrofon hatte er war so hammer ich habe
die ganze zeit meine videos mit meinem
macbook mikrofon aufgenommen mit meinem
verpackten macbook mikrofon und das war
kein tolles macbook pro das war ein
macbook air und das war 2011
ja denn früher trends gegeben hätte wäre
ich auf platz zehn gewesen
[Musik]
das 16 alle öle glätten
dunkel
[Musik]
vom privaten sammlers play bei dem
anderen youtuber und singen
ich habe jetzt ein paar sekunden später
mir fällt auf ich hatte vorkommt euro lp
noch einen kanal
alter
wenn ich dazu jetzt
also das war wirklich ein trucker kanal
von wegen
mach dir irgendwelche bilder videos die
die mich mit sieben jahren überprüfen
oder sondern das waren kanal damit mit
einem kumpel auf gemacht hatte weil wir
bock hatten films und minecraft
letztlich zu machen und der kanal hier
und jetzt alle mal festhalten
rumpel grammys
fragt mich nicht wie wir darauf gekommen
sind schreibt einfach nicht in die
kommentare
lasst uns einfach so stehen als erster
youtube-kanal gibt rumpel grammys hier
klicken einfach mal auch suchen freunde
und wir haben hier zwei videos
die nicht von mir sind ich kriegt man
einfach hier auch rumpel granit auch
nicht
findet man was bei google krumpl granny
und myspace klarer und die grameen any
schrumpelige rally fort
wir gehen wir gehen weg von google
als kumpel gefahr wirklich so mein
erster fußstapfen in der youtube welt
auf dem mond also wenn die youtube welt
der mond wäre ich nicht was das jetzt
würde metapher hier ist ein kumpel von
mir nationen ab und ich haben uns früher
gedacht hey lasst doch mal ein youtube
kanal aufmachen und haben früher auch
immer gramm koks und sohn gedacht okay
das ist eigentlich so schwer und ja war
doch relativ schwer wir hatten keine
migros wir hatten keine vernünftigen
computer und haben dann irgendwie
minecraft und nimmt sophie laden aber
regelmäßig also wir haben wirklich
täglich videos gebracht und mein
werdegang war dann halt so ein bisschen
als ich dann gedacht ok jonas das
kriegen wir alles nicht so ganz weil wir
dann irgendwie ein bisschen ja wir
hatten kein stress aber es gab halt so
ein bisschen aber ich hab mir nicht
hochgeladen
der kanal liefert einfach nicht so dann
habe ich gesagt okay ich mache konkreter
lp auf und danach konnten die firmen ja
oder für ein halbes jahre irgendwie so
und dann habe ich halt kräfte aufgemacht
und hier bin ich und stehe vor euch
fleisch und reis
hi
ich muss tatsächlich mal auf ich gebe
hier noch mal konkreter lp 1
vielleicht finden wir noch in dem video
aufnahmen ganz hinteren seite hier seite
blieben oder so was ich tatsächlich
früher hochgeladen haben was
irgendjemand gering ab lautet hat oder
so dass man nicht alles was
das bin ich aber warum heißt konkret wir
schauen wir hier weil dadurch bekommt
halt relativ viel vor vier jahren
hochgeladen
die achte weite hier ist auch wieder
nicht ich glaube wenn schon finden wir
irgendwelche let's play sie davon
3play wieder eine schallplatte
irgendwelche an leader tsv hartberg
werbungen ttf locker wieder wett
minecraft ist als wenn früher jeder nur
minecraft also zwei auch so geht's ja
auch egal auf jeden fall
ich wollte heute einfach mal ein video
machen und euch mal zeigen okay mein
erstes video auf youtube nicht das video
was ihr auf meinem jetzigen kanal
führungsqualitäten minecraft diamanten
finden video sondern ich hatte wirklich
früher schon zwei kamele einmal
konkreter lp für mich selber gehenden
hochgeladen habe unter vorsprung vor
sechseinhalb jahren oder so also ich
mach das technisch schon lange videos
wenn euch dieses video hier gefallen hat
so mit dem projekt mit dem bekanntesten
schlager ein paar videos angucken last
auf jeden fall waren leica will ich mich
darüber freuen wenn er dieses video
gerade weht bin ich gerade im flieger
nach
ich bin schon in amerika ich bin vor
produziert so ein bisschen also hey ich
bin ja in amerika hier findet ihr oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
darum bin ich auch meinen shop
eingeblendet in dem es eine neue
sommerkollektion weil ein zwei wochen
lebt und hier unten da da wollt ihr
jetzt drauf klicken wir da ein anderes
video verlinkt
ihre produkte